right
yes
thank you good morning everybody this is
the house election law committee in new
hampshire
will turn my mic on and
oh it's amplifying today
um
and
this is business of the house and i ask
that you rise and join me in the pledge
of allegiance
i pledge allegiance to the flag of the
united states of america and to the
republic for which it stands
one nation under god indivisible with
liberty and justice for all
thank you very much everybody as i
stated this is the new hampshire house
election law committee we are scheduled
for a number of public hearings this
morning these are on senate bills that
have been cr passed and crossed over as
they say to us first on the agenda is sb
242 relative to the disqualification of
certain persons from performing the
duties of an election official and with
us is the prime sponsor senator gray
welcome to the committee senator gray
thank you very much
for the record i am james gray
i represent senator district 6
which starts in rochester and goes up
route 11 towards alton barnes and
gilmanton
this bill is
tries to correct a
difference in the statute between
658 24 and 659 58
where the language is different about
who can and cannot work at the elections
pretty much what
we've tried to do
after consultation with the
secretary of state's office is
get that language to agree with each
other
and that's what this bill does
i know that uh you saw it before in an
omnibus bill
and somehow it
didn't make it all the way through the
process so we're back try it again
uh also
i think i have uh
at least four bills in front of you
today
uh but i'm also subbing as the chair
uh you know when you accept the position
as vice chair
and uh but uh senator uh bradley who is
the chair of health and human services
has had his flight cancelled down in
florida to get back
so i'm trying to
split my time which will be a surrogate
for a couple of those bills and i'll be
back with you as best i can
when time permits and if there's any
questions on this one
i'll hear those now and if there's any
questions on the other ones
and you'd like to communicate with me
certainly
best way is either call my cell or call
shannon and she will get
us together
thank you senator i'll have the first
question does senator bradley understand
that the payback for having to spend
more time in florida will be a lot more
than sharing one of your meetings
well
i you know i guess i didn't say on the
phone this morning when he told me that
the second flight was canceled that he
owed me but i think it's understood
all right questions for senator bradley
on sb 242 representative bergeron
thank you thank you senator gray
this is a little bit of a hair splitting
question but
in your conversations
and this refers to the processing of
absentee ballots uh in your
conversations with the secretary of
state um
did it ever come up that it might be
possible to like cordon off an area
within
the uh
voting part you know behind the
checklist to be used for the processing
of absentee ballots because i'm trying
to think of a situation if
a moderator is required under state law
just for clarification does this deal
specifically with this bill or is this a
question for senator gray in light of
his attendance issues uh
it is it is for senator gray okay
i just don't want people looking at the
bill wondering what absentee ballots and
i guess i'm making it longer than i need
to i'm just wondering i think i
understand the question the question you
know because what what we do proposing
the bill is that the
if the moderator's name is on the ballot
you know for other reasons other than
being a moderator that they should not
touch a voted ballot and that would
preclude them from processing those
absentee ballots and i fully agree that
he should
he or she the moderator should
designate one of his alternates or
whatever to process those absentee
ballots and should not
in
the 20 plus years that i was a moderator
any time my name was on the ballot for
school board or or city council
you know i did participate in the
pre-counting of the ballots before the
opening of the election i did pr you
know participate in some of the other
but the things that the moderator would
do like assisting a voter in the voting
booth or any of those things and also
processing of absentee ballots i always
deferred that to someone else which i
believe is appropriate
for the question further question then
then would i be correct in saying that
that within the voting area behind the
checklist where the public cannot roam
um if the moderator cordoned off an area
where absentee ballots would be
processed he could not go into that area
but he could still be in other portions
of the non-public area of the voting
place
the bill specifically doesn't talk about
him being cordoned off from anything
the bill talks about touching the ballot
okay so as long as they're not touching
that voted ballot
or assisting a voter you know
then the bill would allow them to do
those duties
certainly
one of the duties that the moderators
should be doing that some don't is
observing the length of the lines
especially in registration
and others i've taken
you know checklists you know the a to k
and split them in half for
five or ten minutes because of a long
line i have done other things in the
registration table so there's lots of
things the moderator can do
and not that don't involve touching a
voted ballot okay thank you thank you
i'm seeing none thank you very much good
luck on the rest of your morning again i
apologize no issues
all right we'll be in recess for five
minutes
now
so
okay
um
averages
uh
somebody
so
i'm going to declare it to be 9 45 in
this room and open the public hearing on
sb 328 this is relative to the date of
the state primary election as the
committee is aware senator gray the
prime sponsor has a number of other
things going on this morning and welcome
to grant bossie for senator gray good
morning good morning madam chair members
of the election law committee it's good
to be here i am grant bosse from the new
hampshire senate here to introduce
senate bill 328 on behalf of its prime
sponsor senator james gray of rochester
new hampshire currently has the latest
state primary election in the nation
this year it'll be held on september
13th
along with delaware and rhode island
this gives the major party nominees just
eight weeks to mount a general election
campaign often against an incumbent who
didn't have to fight through a primary
add in recounts appeals to the ballot
law commission you're quickly getting to
less than 50 days from election day
before we know who will actually be on
our ballots this puts tremendous
pressure on our election officials to
print absentee and oversee ballots they
always get it done but it's really
really tight
so there's broad agreement that we
should hold our primaries earlier the
question is when
the governor very publicly concerned
about turnout if we hold a primary over
the summer when people are out on
vacation kids are out of school
last year the house position was to move
the primary to june and senate disagreed
the senate holds that june is the wrong
time as it would force sitting
legislators to file and run a campaign
when their time is most in demand here
in concord what we're doing here today
this week exceptionally busy after
crossover you've got all our bills we've
got all your bills
the house and senate are
spending all of their time doing the job
that they were elected to do for a
hundred dollars a year senator greg who
you heard from today's currently
over in hhs hearing 10 of your bills
which you obviously want the senate to
give consideration
now imagine that this week we're also
the filing period for house and senate
members to decide if they were going to
run for re-election or if they had a
candidate's night or a debate or an
interview for their re-election campaign
the senate position is that it is the
wrong time for
especially state house legislators to be
filing and running for re-election in
the primary
senate bill 328 was amended on the
senate floor to move the primary date to
the second week in august that's one
week off from the bill passed last year
out of the senate
allowing candidates a chance to finish
their work in the legislature before
returning to the campaign trail this
would give the secretary of state's
office more time to prepare ukava and
absentee ballots
this amendment received a strong 19-5
vote
showing the senate's strong preference
for an august primary as opposed to one
in june
summer primaries are actually quite
common across the country in fact 14
states will hold their
primary elections in august this year
according to ncsl as close as our
neighbors in vermont as far away as
alaska and hawaii
um
if you have any questions on this i
would be happy to pass them along to
senator gray i would also encourage you
to just send them to shannon she tends
to get answers pretty quickly
we ask for your consideration of senate
bill 328 and thank you for your time
thank you representative bergeron
thank you and this is probably a
question that the sponsors will need to
answer
however are you aware that
the bill provides
that the
last date for a correction
the tuesday before the first wednesday
in may
however
checklists are closed earlier than that
for towns that are holding may town
elections
for example
this year that closing date is april
30th
um
so i guess if you could ask senator gray
if he would be amenable to perhaps
amending that that language so that the
problem is addressed uh he shared your
email with me he's aware of the concern
and if the committee thinks that they
can harmonize
those new hampshire has a lot of
elections
and if if we want to harmonize all those
dates he'd be open to seeing your
solution thank you
representative terozian thank you madam
chair thank you for taking the question
so i'm clear on what the primary date is
in essence it's
pretty much exactly a month earlier than
what it is currently does this affect
the filing date
for running for office at all yes
representative mcdonald
my name is debasi
um this bill as you mentioned is very
similar to the one that the governor
vetoed last year one of his concerns at
the time
was the recruitment of election workers
and so forth is that anyway a concern in
this bill
and if i may also ask madam chairman uh
do you expect a different outcome from
the governor this time i know you can't
speak for him but is there any reason to
expect a different outcome
uh i think we can make the make the case
we've made there are competing interests
a lot of the bills the all the easy laws
have been passed
um you're left with the tough ones
and so there are there are uh competing
values that are all valid uh the senate
believes that a june primary uh balances
those the best uh the governor disagrees
the house has disagreed in the past so
we we're we're hoping uh we might be
able to persuade him this time we'll
follow up madam champion follow up uh
and just to be totally clear i i think i
totally understand what you're talking
about so you're saying that a june
primary would
interfere with legislative duties and
that is why you amended the bill the
senate amended the bill that was a
common argument on the senate floor as
we were debating this over actually
several weeks we put we special ordered
it a few times to try to get a consensus
and we eventually got a 19 to five vote
in favor of the august primary and the
most common argument raised was that
senators and house members are here
in june
not this year we hope to get out in may
but certainly in april and may and into
june um they're getting their work done
they've got deadlines they've got
committees at conference and um a filing
period
right at the end of session primary over
june july and august and then a primary
held in august they felt was the best
best balance of that time
okay thank you thank you further
questions from the committee
seeing none thank you mr bossie we do
have other people signed up to speak on
this bill also signed up to speak on sb
328 relating to the date of the primary
thank
thank you madam chairman and members of
the committee my name is alvin c i live
in loudoun and i'm here on my own behalf
and in support of this bill
i
fully support
moving the primary election earlier i
think the final candidates for the
general election need more time to
campaign
but what i want to address here today is
an unintended consequence
of moving the primary
and that is that the candidates who
follow by nomination papers
all the uh
dates specified in the in the bill or in
the
ls rsas
regarding the
filing of papers
are tied to the primary
the
declaration of
of
candidacy has to be filed during the
primary filing period
and then the dates for getting the
papers
to the
towns to the checklist
supervisors a checklist to check and
then on back to the secretary of state's
office are all tied to a certain number
of weeks before the primary
i would
like to suggest that
in rsa
14a
41 and 43
some changes on that
and this is something that i've provided
before on testimony last year on on the
couple of bills that
went through
but
in fort
655-14a i would suggest that the
instead of having the declaration of
candidacy be filed
during the primary filing period that it
specified as 15 weeks before the general
election that is a slight change that
makes it slightly later but
for
minor parties they sometimes have
national conventions
uh usually in the time frame of between
memorial day and independence day
so that would give them time to
select a
at least for presidential candidates
then for
6 55 41
instead of two weeks before the primary
set it for 10 weeks before the general
election
and that's for
the candidate having his papers
submitted
papers the safe advisor
of the check they need to go to the
supervisor checks weeks 13 weeks before
the general election rather than five
weeks before the primary
the supervisor of the checklist have to
have them completed
ten weeks before the general election
instead of two weeks before the primary
and then the final one was getting them
to the secretary of state which
uh currently in 655-43 says one week
before the primary
this would make it nine weeks before the
general election
and these
i just
went through the
political calendar that we use
and
just counted back from
based on this year and and two years ago
i realized this bill doesn't take effect
until next year so it would not affect
this year
and just for reference
that uh 15 weeks before the uh general
election
if it were this year would be
the secretary's state has been given a
copy of this
uh i have not heard back from him
whether there was any
issues on this
um
but it's basically identical to what it
is right now with the exception of the
declaration of candidacy
and i'll be happy to take any questions
if there are any thank you mr c any
questions
seeing none thank you also signed up to
speak on sb 328 is dan mcguire
the honorable dan mcguire from epsom
formerly i guess
i know i think you're always honorable
at that point
um possibly future all right
thank you very much madam chair members
of the committee for the record my name
is dan mcguire i'm from the town of
epsom
um i'm in favor of moving the primary i
actually would prefer the june date but
i think this is a reasonable compromise
the current calendar
is very much um to the liking of how the
house members i think
um in general when you when you're a
you don't have to raise much money for
your campaign typically people fund
their own campaigns
most members
uh either will have a a
the general election will be the
significant election for them or the
primary election will be the significant
election for them uh not both
um
and
and so and it's very comfortable to
finish your work if you're an incumbent
house member to finish your work in the
house
in june sign up for reelection if the
primary is your primary election work on
it over the summer
and have it and you're done if the
general is your primary election
you coast during the summer and then
then two months is plenty to run for the
house
but if you're someone trying to break
into one of the higher offices
the statewide offices or executive
council and so on
then this current schedule
is really bad for you it's it's it's
very favorable for incumbents
but it's very
very difficult for challengers because
those are offices that require a lot of
money
for ads and and
staff and all that sort of thing
and and so
frequently when you're a challenger uh
if when you're an incumbent
you you typically are not seriously
challenged in the primary right you're
someone who's who's an incumbent uh can
frequently
is nearly guaranteed not always
obviously but nearly guaranteed to win
their primary and so they know they're
going to be in the general election and
they know
they can spend the summer
um raising money and getting prepared
for the general election and so on
getting their staff together and all
that but frequently there's multiple in
the other party there's multiple
challengers they don't know if they're
going to be the winner it's it's
frequently competitive
and so they don't find out to
mid-september
whether or not they're going to have a
general election and that leaves them
such a short time two months
to
raise money get a general election
campaign together and go up against a
typically much better funded incumbent
so
this bill
expands that period of time that general
election period
by about 50 percent right so it's
currently roughly two months it adds a
month to it so that's a significant
improvement for and and
it makes it a little bit fairer i mean
it clearly incumbents will still have
big advantages
there's no way around that
but this this
makes that crucial period prior to the
general election roughly 50 percent
longer and that that i think is very
important for fairness
for challengers so it's not as fun it's
not as nice for house members
but it's not that much different i don't
think and it's it's it's something
i would hope that you would um
you would pass thank you madam troop
thank you questions for
mr mcguire
seeing none thank you yeah you've had
this bill over and over so
well it's nice to hear that that house
members have it easier on something
there you go
um also signed up to speak on this is
patricia lovejoy from the secretary of
good morning madam chair thank you my
name is patricia lovejoy i am the senior
deputy secretary of state uh on
on this bill 328 the date of the primary
the secretary of state's
position is
we're concerned about voter turnout new
hampshire has a history of very good
voter turnout even in our primaries
and we're concerned that
you know august is a time of vacation
kids are out of school
it's a summer state of mind
unlike many of us who've been involved
in politics many of the general public
do not
tune in to politics until the calendar
turns over to september so we're
concerned about the uh turn uh turnout
that's our that's our biggest concern um
just a couple other issues for you to
keep in the back of your mind during the
sign up period this is in may
we do have an alternate town election
day which is in may there are many of
our municipalities that have their
elections at that time this year that
date is may 10th
so it can be a concern for
town
town clerk's offices
we are also concerned about the
recruitment of
of workers at the at the polls
obviously every 10 years when we have
redistricting
districts are not always set this bill
does uh on page
one
in
lines five through seven does give the
secretary of state's office the ability
to change the date of the primary and
the date of signups
currently the governor has signed the
house districts but those are the only
ones that are set in stone at this point
and we are um in the first week of april
so that if the primary is uh the sign up
is the beginning of may
depending upon how long that process
takes so you may have every 10 years
that the primary is moved off so we just
wanted to bring those concerns to you
and i would be
willing to take any questions
questions from ms lovejoy representative
terrezan thank you madam chair thank you
uh deputy secretary
so
we've heard uh this legislative year um
from many of the concern that you heard
from
the last couple of speakers on this
legislation of the concern with the very
tight
time frame between the primary date and
the general election date
how do we balance that
very i think
real concern with the concern that you
bring up
does this does the department have a
an alternate date they might suggest uh
we
we actually prefer the current date that
uh we have but as far as the the time
period for us getting ballots and you
will call the ballots we have always
managed to to do that even though it is
a tight time frame um i guess the reason
you get paid the big bucks is to uh to
make these decisions obviously whatever
decision
the legislature and the governor signs
off on we will make work
our i said our big concern is voter
turnout i mean
we are always
concerned about keeping our first in the
nation primary and one of the factors
that does go into that choosing of who's
going to be the first in the nation
primary is voter turnout
follow-up
quick follow-up i'm glad you brought
that up because in order to keep that
first in the nation primary we usually
have a very early primary for that so
that kind of contradicts what you said
in regard to september but
i don't know if you have any any
comments on that
no i think i i understand uh the
i i get the irony
but
as far as for our state elections um the
secretary's state's
office
prefers the um
the september primary but we will make
whatever whatever you decide and
whatever the legislature and the
governor decides work we just wanted to
bring our concerns to you on to have
while you're making that decision
thank you
representative mcdonald
thank you madam chairman good morning
good morning um you had mentioned that
um the may filing period would be of
concern for local election officials and
i know that was a concern
was filing period ended up being in
march for june primary
and i don't know if you can answer this
question obviously you're not a local
election official but do you have any
insight in terms of how
town clerks and other local election
officials around the state generally
regard a possible state primary change
we have not pulled them i don't know but
i'm i'm sure that those that have the
may elections which obviously is a much
smaller
portion of our municipalities but we do
have municipalities that use that
alternate date in may
those town clerks i'm sure
would be concerned they would be um
outnumbered by by others but uh for for
those that do have the may
uh may day this
puts more work into a um into a shorter
period of time
thank you
seeing none thank you for being with us
this morning
i'm going to close the hearing on sb
328 our next hearing is on 364. this is
relative to the use of electronic poll
books the prime sponsor on this bill is
senator
perkins coca is there anybody here to
representative hayward would you be a
sport and introduce this bill please
uh i haven't decided whether he's gonna
so uh
thank you madam chair i appreciate it
welcome to the committee this morning
so uh we have
before says uh
senate bill 364. it's an act relative to
the use of electronic poll books
and
in
this uh is an obvious
outcome of a study
that
had been
looked at in the past
so
thank you representative hayward that
was terrific
and i i don't think anybody has any
questions here i appreciate that as well
thank you
um i don't have anybody else signed up
oh oh i do i'm sorry patricia lovejoy
from the secretary of state thank you
for
there we go
once again good morning uh patricia
lovejoy at the secretary of state's
office
uh this bill is related to um
the electronic polls
the
ebooks
it's a simple correction
it relates to the maximum time lag
between when the electronic poll books
have to be updated with the paper um
books and it changes it from 10 to 30
minutes
after a thorough e poll book pilot
program the general court enacted a
permanent electronic poll book program
and after being in effect for
several municipalities and special
elections the local clerks and election
officials brought to light a few things
that they um wish to have changed and
this is the uh the major one so it gives
poll workers a little additional time
more and more towns have been using the
e-pole books and those that have used it
have been
extremely happy with it
i expect that as time goes by more and
more towns will be
will be adopting it it moves the lines
through
much much more quickly
we do have a rfp out that we expect is
going to
um
that the work will be done in time for
this year's election which will allow
the e-pull books to
automatically update the voter
registration system currently right now
what your town
which your
supervisors of the checklist do at the
end of each election
if i'm sure you were all familiar with
the check-in forms and there is a
little scam
barcode
and the supervisors the checklist
afterward have to go through
you know line by line everyone who voted
and scan the um
scan it into the
voter registration system
with the new changes that will be made
to the e-poll book which we are
quite sure will be um available for this
this november the system will
automatically update it and that will
include if somebody has now if you've
used a um
a massachusetts license as your id
it is we note on the
on the checklist that it was from
massachusetts even that kind of
information will be updated
automatically through the um poll books
so this is really a relatively simple
change of uh giving them a little bit of
additional time a time lag between
updating the
poll books and the paper back up
thank you
thank you madam chairman and thank you
deputy secretary of state
how many electro
how well backed up is electronic
pullback
how well backed up is it electronically
um
it is uh i'm not as much of a tech i
can't give you the exact technical um
terms but it is very well um backed up
they have been
um
they have been tested significantly and
that's why there is a
continual backup also with the paper
with the paper
checklist
uh follow-up follow-up thank you
so if
so so if the primary electronic system
fails within that 30 minutes it is
already thoroughly backed up
electronically it's backed up
electronically and we are printing out
the um the paper one also okay thank you
uh i have one how many towns have used
it do you know i don't have the the
number off the top of my head i mean are
we talking two are we talking oh no
there's more than there's more than that
there were several that started doing
the um
uh
the original testing i don't know how
many there are additional ones that have
signed up for for this year but i don't
have that number i can get that to you
all right i'm not seeing any ques more
questions so thank you very much also
signed up
for this uh for speaking on this is
thank you madam chair and h grace from
the new hampshire municipal association
we support this
change
as
the deputy secretary of state stated um
this simply increases the amount of time
um for the uh
parallel uh check-in
lag time to be no more than 30 minutes
instead of the current 10 and my
understanding for that request is that
it was simply
because typically
when an issue arises as a technical
issue and they're trying to troubleshoot
it might take a little bit more than 10
minutes
as far as
the chair's question for movement
towards electronic poll books
i can tell you that every year nhma does
do a training for
moderators for the past several years
we've emphasized
kind of this electronic poll book shift
and usage
and there's been an incredibly high
amount of interest in that
because of the speed at which that can
increase
elections
and ensure that
that everything is being done correctly
and at the same time so i would imagine
that the next few years we'll see most
municipalities that have
uh you know good internet connectivity
at their polling locations be uh try to
shift towards electronic poll books
thank you questions
for
is there anybody else here who wants to
i'm not seeing anybody so at this time
i'm going to close the hearing on 364.
our next hearing
is 365 relative to absentee
ballot outer envelopes and that is not
scheduled to commence until 10 30
so we have a 15 minute recess thank you
everybody
um
ridiculous
is
um
i'm
yes
2016.
is
no indoor plumbing
um
see
okay
friday
um
oh
is
um
all right it is 10 30 by at least one of
the timepieces available to me
the house election law committee is back
in session we are scheduled for a public
hearing relative to the absentee ballot
outer envelope and here to present the
bill to the committee as the prime
sponsor welcome back senator gray
uh thank you for the record even though
my name is james gray i'm senator
representing district six
which starts in rochester goes up route
11 to alton barnes and gilmanton
um
one of the great
that we had
during the past elections was the
ability to pre-process
the absentee ballots it was well
received by moderators well received by
i tell people that a lot of the things
that they did about marking the
checklist can actually be done
automatically
but
the other thing is is the absentee
ballots being able to open
that outer envelope and be able to
identify the signatures
one of the things that was most
beneficial to the voter was the ability
to correct
any errors that were found either
missing signatures
or
other
problems with that ballot
so the question came up is okay well why
do we have an outer envelope
the only reason we have our outer
envelope really
from what i've been able to find out is
when i go put it in the mail i need a
place to put the stamps and the address
okay well then a person who votes at the
city or town hall in person why do they
need an honorable
answer is they don't
and if they don't have the outer
envelope they hand me back the ballot i
can look at the signature if i'm the
clerk
and say
well you know
you probably ought to you know sign it
down here where you're supposed to or
whatever else is the problem
and give them that ability to correct
their signature right there
if one comes in in the mail there's no
reason for it to be part of the absentee
ballot process which is the way the law
was structured prior to this
the clerk ought to be able to open those
envelopes
attach all the appropriate forms
and the disability people will say that
that uh amendment that they would like
to uh this bill
and hopefully i've talked them out of
some of it but there is a form right now
and that could be attached also along
with the application and i'm sure that
if they choose to they'll be able to
testify on that but again
you know that's a training thing but
the application can be stapled to it
we were asked by the clerks to also
include the address
so that it was easier
i'm told that children right now
in schools are taught how to make a
cursive first letter of their first name
and a cursive first letter of their last
name and then make a squiggle
believe it or not that's what i've been
told
and so
trying to decipher
some of those
and i'm going to put air quotes around
it signatures are very difficult
so having the address in there which was
added to the bill
will be very helpful to the clerks
this also
because we have an injunction against
looking at the signatures because of a
court order
the two things that the court said if
you want to go back and check signatures
the things that you need to do
is one
give the voter the ability to correct if
they did something wrong
this does that
and the other thing is training in the
signatures
and that would be something that the
secretary of state would do
to those individuals
and at that time
the secretary of state probably would be
able to
petition the court to lift the court
order and
again go back to
at least reviewing those signatures
on that note i want to tell you in the
20 plus years that i was a moderator
i used to look for reasons to accept the
signatures not reasons to reject the
signatures
which is very important when we're
looking at those
these affidavits
i used to go to the original application
which used to be at the polls
and look at the printing because
sometimes the printing told me more
about that person
and if he had the little circle here or
a straight line here
that i use that as a reason to say that
there is
more evidence than not that the
signature is made by the right
individual
and with that i will
offer myself for other
questions before i run back across the
street
questions from committee members for
i'm not seeing any thank you have a nice
stroll thank you now
all right and how did grant do did he do
bye um
also signed up to speak on 365
um is karen rosenberg and james zegra i
don't know zegra
why don't you you can both kimono thank
you
i got it right
welcome
thank you good morning good morning for
the record i'm karen rosenberg i'm the
policy director at disability rights
center and this is my colleague i'm
james egram a staff attorney at
disability rights center
so um
i think i
violated a prime directive which is the
kiss role keep it simple and stupid
when i discussed an issue that our
office identified with this bill
so i i brought james here to explain to
you why we um
think that
although the bill was intended to just
eliminate the rule for the
requirement of the outer envelope that
it there may be some risk without a tiny
adjustment um that certain votes may be
not counted for people with disabilities
so i'm going to have james explain that
to you because he knows this far better
than i do all right thank you sure good
morning um so the concern with the bill
that we have as written is that it
doesn't account for a new accessible
absentee voting program that was put
into place by the secretary of state in
2020.
essentially the program allows people
with print disabilities who are blind or
who are otherwise unable to fill out a
paper ballot on their own
to complete a ballot um privately and
independently
so without getting too into the weeds
about this accessible absentee program
basically eligible voters request that a
ballot is sent to them and along with
the ballot is a separate uh voter
affidavit that is sent to them the voter
will fill out the affidavit and fill out
their ballot electronically they print
out a piece of paper with the ballot
print out a piece of paper with their
affidavit and they put the ballot inside
the affidavit envelope just like every
other voter does but the instructions
that the secretary of state's office
give to voters says that they should
take that affidavit that separate
printed affidavit and put that in the
outer mailing envelope
um because people these folks have print
disabilities they're not able to sign
the envelopes themselves the affidavit
envelope like most voters so in lieu of
that they fill out a separate affidavit
put it inside the mailing envelope and
either hand deliver it or they mail it
to the city or town clerk
now the problem with well it's not
really a problem but it's just maybe
perhaps a small oversight with the bill
is that the um you know the the
the voters are instructed to put it in
the outer envelope and the state
election officials are instructed that
this affidavit is going to come
separately in that outer envelope as
well
however the bill doesn't have any
guidance in it to tell elected officials
that they need to somehow secure this
affidavit to the affidavit envelope so
as a consequence what might happen
is that
the the town clerk when they're
pre-processing the outer envelopes
something may happen to that affidavit
and it may not be attached properly or
affects to that inner affidavit envelope
and when that happens come election day
that ballot could be tossed because
there's no signature on the affidavit
envelope so even though the voter had
filled out their affidavit in accordance
with the instructions provided to them
by the secretary's office
their vote may not count and so
we just wanted to address that concern
so i actually brought a one paragraph
potential amendment that you might
consider um which i provided to
representative griffin but i have copies
for you all if i don't think i actually
took it
because i have this thing about getting
paper before it's time to look at it so
if you can give it to representative
quayley and then have him pass it to
representative hayward and we'll we'll
get it around i'm having a little
trouble putting my hands around what it
is you're talking you're talking about
as far as the issue
um and representative bergeron before i
open it up to further questions do we
have anything currently in a bill that
i can't recall seeing any house or
senate bills that dealt with a matter of
pre-processing and the pre-processing
expired under current law given the the
way it was passed for 2020 correct
correct
there is a statute in existing law which
i believe allows election officials to
tear open the outer envelope prior to
election day but they can't remove
anything from it
it's just a matter of taking letter
openers and i don't really know how much
time that saves anybody anyway um
but that's the only thing i can think of
in terms of pre-processing
thank you uh before we go on what is
this so i've also just for your
information this is um a settlement
agreement that the secretary of state's
office entered into and it what it inc
the reason it's tabbed is it has the
process tab so you can see what the
process is that they agreed to all right
um
so i'm not clear that there's any
provision for pre-processing so we're
going to have to
um
there it has not been unanimity between
the house and the senate on that
procedure
interesting
so um
so really all we just want to make sure
is that these um affidavits that people
who either can't see to hand fill a
document or can't physically hand write
the affidavit that their
um affidavits
are not lost and separated from their
actual ballots
so
um that's why it really could be
accomplished with a very simple um one
paragraph i think amendment
for your okay so
which is what you passed out that's
that's what i passed out
but then i thought for your information
that you might want to see the procedure
so that's why i handed out the
settlement agreement and tabbed the
procedure if you felt like reading that
because
okay representative hayward
well thank you madam chair and uh thank
you for
taking this question and without the
benefit of your one paragraph
what you described to me
do you think that that is a
requirement in the rsa or is that better
served as a direction on by exception
from the
well i suppose it could be in the
included in the election procedure
manual that the secretary of state
publishes and distributes every year
and certainly the secretary of state has
published guidance to local election
officials about how to
address these accessible absentee votes
that is one avenue for it but my concern
is that if it's not codified into law
there's no statutory requirement for
election officials to attend training
from the secretary of state's office so
you know things may fall through the
cracks
there's also in the bill as it currently
is
written there is a provision in
paragraph
section four that talks about attaching
the application for an absentee ballot
to the ballot
so there is some guidance there is
something in the statute about that
application but not the affidavit
so
i don't know if that would create some
confusion to only um have in a you know
in statute that you attach the
application and not have in statute that
you also apply
attach that separately printed affidavit
thank you representative hamlet
thank you madam chair
um my my question is actually for you or
or maybe for you
i'm
confused as to
um we don't this doesn't have to be done
in a pre-processing
sect session right this can be done
right at the
you know
right whenever this clerk receives the
absentee ballot or or whenever the you
know they receive it at the polls they
just
kind of process it the way they do now
i
didn't i didn't think it required a
pre-processing
session
yeah i perhaps i misspoke um and and did
not realize that pre-processing was a
term of art but excuse me for a minute
are there extras of the one page
amendment somewhere there right there
olivia has them for you representative
clearly
i'm sorry for that interruption
oh that's okay perhaps i misspoke about
the term pre-processing what i meant was
the ability for
local city and town clerks or election
officials to open up the outer envelopes
ahead of time which you know i agree is
a great thing i think it makes it more
efficient and i understand that the
feedback has been overwhelmingly
positive throughout the state i just my
concern is that that separate affidavit
that is printed out may get lost in the
shuffle if there's nothing to um
mandate that it gets attached
just for the record thank you my town is
not
my will not be doing pre-processing in
the future they didn't think the process
and created a lot of
other questions from committee members
representative murrah thank you
um
is the printed separate printed
affidavit put inside the inner envelope
no it's inside the okay just sorry it's
inside the it's in the outer envelope
so
the ballot would then be private right
thank you
follow up thank you
um
it looks to me like your proposed
amendment
tries to solve a problem that is already
there in the law
and not a problem that's being
introduced by this
by this
proposed piece of legislation that the
the
ambiguity about what to do with this
printed affidavit
is already present in the rsas and it's
not it's not an ambiguity introduced by
this piece of legislation is that fair
does it
i think that's a fair assessment because
this program is so new it just debuted
in the 2020 election um it is um
something that the statutes haven't
the subjects have not addressed have not
addressed yet yes right
okay
i'm gonna hope that
ms lovejoy is gonna chime in on this
when this is over though i don't have a
pink
card from her
i'm seeing then thank you very much
yeah that's fine you can get it to me
afterwards
thank you madam chair um patricia
lovejoy secretary of state's office
uh
the obviously what the last speaker was
talking about for the um those
print the ability to
ver someone who is
[Music]
visually impaired to print off their
their ballot
as part of the training
are being informed that um
that those
they need to be kept with the um with
the affidavit envelope because they
haven't filled out the affidavit
envelope they have printed off their um
their affidavit uh
currently
without this law we are not opening
the envelopes until
until the day that you process them all
right so so just to interrupt so i'm
correct that this
the underlying statute in this that
we're amending
is not in effect
correct okay yes so what this
bill is doing
you submit your absentee ballot by mail
this allows the clerk to open the
outside envelope
eyeball it
say the person didn't sign it or they
didn't check off their reason so they
would notify the voter that you need to
come in and cure your um affidavit and
just for clarification on the purp on
the process that's because this
particular voter as compared to the
voters we may have just heard yes
has been able to actually complete the
outer envelope that holds the balance
when the outer envelope is opened the
clerk is looking at that completed outer
envelope correct
and in these voters case when they open
the um
the envelope the outside envelope they
would find this piece of paper
inside that's just back up from a
procedural because
sometimes i pretend to be an engineer
and need things in process
so when someone is using this process
because of disability and doing their
electronically provided ballot
they are not able to do the envelope
affidavit correct so the
without this piece of paper
this particular ballot that's printed
off as allowed by law as compared to the
official ballot that gets sent to some
people
gets put in that envelope the affidavit
envelope but there is no ability to
complete the outer envelope so this
secretary of state's office under this
agreement
which is not in law it's part of a case
settlement
has a separate affidavit that is then
able to be done
for this particular absentee ballot
correct so the
voter
affidavit that's printed off done by the
disabled voter yes or by a person
assisting that voter uh it can be it can
be either okay so if it's a person
assisting the voter can't they do the
they they potentially could i'm thinking
of one of my neighbors she has
macro degeneration
she can blow something up on her
computer screen
and
complete to this
and print it off
submit it you know put it into the
outside envelope and that would go to
these
to the town clerk when the town clerk
opens
the affidavit envelope is not going to
be completed at all but there will be
this
special um
affidavit in effect that takes the place
of
the outside part of the affidavit
envelope their ballot is still
inside
that envelope
but that would only
um occur
if this if this bill is passed
now when the clerk receives
the absentee ballot and by mail
they can slit it open
look into it look at the apps
affidavit envelope to make sure that it
was properly done
no without this bill all of that happens
on
on election day
and this bill also says that
if you are going to the town clerk's
office in voting in person absentee
there's no reason for the upside
envelope
i mean the
that you complete you complete the
affidavit envelope put your ballot
inside there's no reason to then take
that one and put it inside
uh another outside envelope because
you're not mailing it you're handing it
to the um
to the town clerk
right okay and
is a member of the committee correct in
that the clerk's office is allowed to
open the as it is now without this bill
is allowed to open the outer envelope
before election day
they can slit them open but that's it
they don't do
right don't look they don't look don't
peek okay
so
is the problem that is
they are trying to address by this
amendment
in existence
regardless of whether
could you restate that well currently
is essentially not in law the
pre-processing is not part of the law
correct and it appears to me and i'm
sorry committee members for monopolizing
this but i'm really having a hard time
following what the issue is here
um
so it appears to me
that
currently on election day
absent the slitting open of the envelope
perhaps
the
envelope with the ballot and the
affidavit as is currently provided in
law are together on that day at that
place
the issue becomes if it is looked at
before election day
that there is concern
the issue as i understand it
the
affidavit
that under this settlement process is
being printed
separately has no place in law as it is
currently in existence to keep it with
the ballot envelope
so that if you pre-process these ballots
and there is no specific provision to
attach this affidavit to the ballot
envelope between the time of
pre-processing and the election
if something happens to that affidavit
and it gets separated you will now have
an absentee ballot with an envelope that
has not been completed at all and
therefore it will be ruled
invalid by the moderator and not counted
and that
so this issue only comes up with the
pre-processing because if you open it
all on election day it should be there
with the ballot it will be there with
the ballot um
part of this is what is the problem that
we're trying to
that this bill is trying to correct um
many times we have bills that are in
search of a problem but is what is what
is the problem that's trying to be
corrected here
in this last election when we did the
pre-processing in you know in in many
many towns um
they found
several
affidavit envelopes that were not
properly completed um i helped with
doing the pre-processing in my town
and there were some people who just
forgot to sign it
and because this happened a few days
beforehand when we did the
pre-processing it was easier to contact
those voters and say there's a problem
with your absentee ballot with your with
your affidavit
you can either come and vote in person
that day if if you are now able to
or you can come in ahead of time and
correct this problem
if you
open everything
on
election day and you don't start till
say noon
the
ability to contact that voter and ex so
that they could come in and cure the
absolutely that's a different issue than
the amendment the amendment is trying to
address the issue that's the but that
that's what this bill for not we don't
have the an amendment yet but a
potential amendment the proposal
this bill
is
that's that's the problem that this bill
was trying to address was that there are
people who
um incorrectly fill out their affidavit
envelopes forget to sign them etc
and this gives the town clerk the
ability to just look they're not
pre-processing i mean that's the they're
not pre-processing they're just opening
it up looking at it does it appear you
know is there anything obvious
that we need to have the voter come in
and correct so that's what the purpose
of this bill is the amendment
if you did that and you you opened up
the envelope and it has this special
um affidavit nobody is taking anything
out of the envelope
so
that
um
special affidavit that's been printed
off that's not using the affidavit
envelope would not be being removed
nothing is being removed from the
envelope it's the ability to look at it
see if something needs to be cured
and be able to contact the voter that's
that's the logic behind um what this
bill is trying to do all right i think i
got it now okay
any other questions any other questions
now that the chair has monopolized that
sorry
i should have made widgets as a child
representative just wanted to say thank
you thank you for monopolizing that that
now i think i understand it
okay
and i will fill out a pink card
thank you
um that is my last speaker on 365. is
there anybody else here who wants to
speak on 365.
not seeing anyone i'm going to close the
public hearing and open the public
hearing
on sb 366
requiring an audit of ballots cast in
the election
senator gray needed to
leave and
um
representative hayward can you just
introduce grab a pink card and introduce
this again for us oh i'm sorry
oh you are thank you okay
great and if you can just give me a pink
card when you're done it's up there
uh yep sorry miss salfano
welcome sorry i made your entrance so
dramatic here
no problem good morning madam chair
members of the committee i'm carol
alfano i'm the senate communications
director and it's my privilege to
introduce senate bill 366 for its prime
sponsor senator jim gray from rochester
district 6.
this bill requires the secretary of
state to conduct an audit of ballots
cast in the 2022 state primary and
general elections
a random selection of the acuvue vote
machines will be chosen from across the
state to be audited by a high-speed
scanner certified by the ballot
commission this bill was a
recommendation and includes the
recommendations of the committee to post
excuse me the committee to study
post-election audit counting devices
senator gray appreciates your support on
sb 366. that concludes my introduction
and thank you for your consideration
thank you
i didn't hear a big opening for
questions but does anybody have any
questions
representative bergeron thank you and
um i do have
patricia lovejoy has signed up to speak
to it and is familiar with the
workings of this bill so i'm just saying
that before you ask your question for ms
alfano
if i may
my understanding after reading this bill
and actually some comments made by
senator gray on monday during some other
hearings this really is a testing of the
accuracy of the accuvope machines not
necessarily an audit of the election
results is that correct
because
for example there are no audits being
done for towns with uh paper ballots
representative i would have to defer to
the secretary of state's office or have
senator gray follow up on your question
okay
with that said i'll just add that uh it
really doesn't matter to me i was just
curious that about the use of the term
audit i see it more as a testing of the
machines which is which is fine
thank you very much for coming thank you
all right
patricia lovejoy from the secretary of
state has also signed up to speak on
thank you madam chair once again
patricia well joint secretary of state's
office
this bill is you know is attempting to
address
voters concern about accuracy of
of elections
it is not an audit
in that
it is only looking at one
machine
so
i have no idea how many machines
manchester has but i'm assuming it's a
lot more than one
um this would be testing that one one
machine that was picked from from that
town uh we're talking about you know say
for the like it's three
no less than four four devices that the
secretary of state's office would have
picked ahead of time what towns we would
not notify them
need to be sneaky
and if they have more than one machine
um they would not be noted they would no
any town would be notified by noon that
their town was one of the ones selected
but they would not be told what machine
was selected so this is testing
one machine
um
i i'm not really sure if we need to put
the language in here or if it's just in
our um
in our procedures but you'd have to make
very sure
that
all boxes
are boxed by all ballots are boxed by
what machine they came out of
and
you have to make very sure that you
don't
take anything that comes from the side
bin if a ballot can't be put in
uh that it needs to go into a side bin
you will have a
a
bill on friday
that's talking about provisional ballots
and those provisional ballots in that uh
in that
bill
would be put into the side pocket to be
hand counted at the end of the day
so if i've got machine number five
in manchester
and there are
um ballots that are going to be hand
counted
i would have to make very sure that i'm
not including those
when i'm boxing up the uh ballots
that are
related to machine number five because
the machine
is not going to have counted those
so there's
i you know i have some concerns that we
may not you know you may not always get
your apples to apples
um
and all of this
needs to be done
before friday morning the election ends
on tuesday tuesday night everyone is
doing their their counting um many times
it's into
uh wednesday morning before they are
completed uh the secretary of state's
office you know much of monday and much
of wednesday is
trying to get all of the um
all the results from the various
locations
these audits with the high-speed scanner
i guess would probably have to be done
on on thursday the ballots need to be
brought to the secretary of state's
office from the archives and
using this high speed scanner which we
need to purchase
my personal thoughts are what
you know for each bill what is the
problem we're trying to um we're trying
to solve and in this
bill the issue is voter confidence
um
i i question whether or not it needs to
be done by friday morning
if what we're trying to do is
um prove that the accuvope machines
are correct and we're doing it on random
sample
we could potentially if we have this
high speed scanner do a lot more than
four but do it
you know a little bit later than um
than two days
after the election
if if what you're trying to get at is to
give voters confidence
that these accuvope machines correctly
counted their
ballots
um
it
i believe it could be done you know
potentially you know the following week
or after recounts um but obviously that
is
a issue that is up for uh the house and
the senate and the governor to decide
whichever way you end up doing it we
will at the secretary of state's office
we will do
whatever the whatever the final
legislation is but there will be
obviously a um
a time crunch there of getting this done
by friday morning
further question representative bergeron
uh thank you madam chair
as you were speaking it occurred to me
there are a lot of polling places that
do use two machines when there's going
to be a high turnout yes
particularly during the presidential
election
if you're now requiring the election
officials to keep the ballot segregated
from you know those used in machine x
and those used in machine y
aren't we introducing the possibility of
human error that someone makes the
mistake and puts ballots from machine x
into cartons from for machine y
and then the results you're going to get
actually will not restore confidence in
people in these machines because the
numbers will be different will actually
cause people get upset that the machines
were inaccurate so to get to my question
wouldn't it make more sense to test both
machines in the polling place and test
all the ballots in the polling place so
that you get a total number that that we
can feel confident actually reflects
the accuracy of the machine
that would be a a recount such as we are
are we we already do when people request
a um a recount
you would also have the
um the the possibility of
well the ones that are hand counted all
get pulled separately anyway so that
probably is not as much of a of an issue
that the hand count
ballots from machine number five got
put in with machine number five uh
acuvo
ballots
but you're right if if
and and towns are not used to having to
keep them
separate
this would require that they do keep
them separate and if
if
ballots from
you you had three quarters of a box from
machine four and somebody puts you know
fills it up with the ones from machine
three and then you are trying to count
you're right it
it could
uh do the opposite of what the bill is
is trying to do which is to you know
to restore confidence i'm uh
to have more confidence i guess i'm
hoping that people have not completely
lost confidence in our active vote
machines because they have been very
accurate okay thank you
further questions from committee members
representative hayward
yes thank you madam chair and thank you
for taking the question um
and it's it's
somewhat rhetorical i suppose
but are you not missing an important
piece of data on the
by taking the ones from the side pocket
and not counting them now certainly they
did not run through the machine so
as a check on
the accuracy of the count
they are not effective but
because they were rejected by the
machine
there is data
to be
analyzed
from those numbers as well
the purpose of this bill
is just to
confirm the accuracy of the count of the
accuvope machine
and those hand counted what for whatever
reason that a ballot ended up in the
side pocket and needs to be hand counted
would have to be excluded if the purpose
of your
of your action is to
confirm the accuracy
of the accuvolk machine if you were
doing a full audit then yes you
obviously need to or a recount i should
use or not if you're doing a full
recount
you would obviously need to have those
um
those ballots included in your in your
recount but if you're
just trying to test
the accuracy of the accuvolk machine
you would not include those
thank you further questions
everybody said representative quailey
thank you madam chairman
thank you
uh
under part four
state general election audits it says
the secretary of state shall randomly
select one to three percent of accu-vote
devices
my question is do you know or have an
estimate for how many accuvote devices
i do not know i can i can get that
information for you i know we have about
a hundred and
twelve hundred and thirteen towns that
do hand counts
so
it's about this it's just for purposes
of the mass assume it's the same amount
for accupo because it's 240 something
polling places
minus 113 112 13 is 120 but some of
those use two devices yeah even my town
of stratum has two yeah
and we're seventeen thousand yeah and
assume there's at least 150 probably
accu vote machines being used at least
that's probably a good estimate but i
can find out the exact number if you
well i was really just looking for kind
of an order of magnitude
it's in the hundreds low hundreds
basically is what you're telling me low
to mid
thank you
seeing none thank you very much you're
welcome um
i also have a card for speaking to this
thank you madam chairman and member of
the committee my name is alvin c i live
in loudoun and i'm here on my own behalf
i was at the
senate hearing for this bill and also at
study commission
meetings which developed this
and
i do recall that one of the stated
intents was to do this before the
deadline for filing for a recount
and that's why it was to be done before
friday afternoon
so that
if any candidate
affected by this saw this they could say
okay yes i'm going to call for recount
i would say that in the event of a
mix-up of ballots that shouldn't have
been counted or scanned and balanced
that should have been scanned if they
were in the wrong
box for the wrong machine or however
might have gotten mixed up
that should show a fairly big error
and if that's the case then the
candidates may ask for a recount
or
there may be a justification for doing a
an audit of that town
but i'm not sure what the specific
intent was there if that happened
and if there's any questions i'll answer
them
thank you questions for alvin c
c none thanks for coming
i don't have anybody else signed up to
speak on sb 366.
excuse me so i'm going to close the
public hearing on 366 and open the
public hearing on 405.
this is relative to fines and penalties
for election law violations is anybody
here to introduce
representative hayward is here to
welcome representative hayward uh thank
you madam chair and i
noticed that i did not introduce myself
the last time i got up here so this time
i'm representative pete hayward from uh
strawford county district one
representing the towns today at least of
so i i'm introducing senate bill 405 fn
relative to fines and penalties for
election law violations
you can see who the sponsors are and uh
they're not there
is
i'm seeing none great job thank you
representative hayward thank you madam
chair okay
all right everybody has the bill
um
anybody have any explanation or comment
i'm not seeing any so i'm going to close
the public hearing on 405.
right so we are actually ahead of
schedule for 4 27
so we will reopen at 11 30. thank you
everybody
wow
uh
secrets
we are back this is the house election
law committee of the new hampshire house
today is wednesday april 6th
and we are
breaking from our recess to take up our
last bill of the morning
we are scheduled at 11 30 for sb
427 modifying the absentee voter
registration process absentee ballot
application and absentee voting process
and with us to introduce the bill we
welcome senator susie here
prime sponsor of
hb427 welcome good morning good morning
thank you so much madam chair members of
the committee i'm so thrilled that
you're running on time you're doing a
great job today
for the record i'm donna soucy i
represent senate district 18 comprised
of the town of litchfield and the city
of manchester's wards five through nine
and i don't want you to
be deceived by the title of the bill the
bill was amended
since its introduction the bill changed
fairly significantly and was very
narrowed in scope
we did a lot of work on the bill in
senate election law and we got it to a
place where it passed the committee
currently
the law allows a voter to vote or
register to vote by absentee for reasons
of disability
as amended senate bill 427 expands the
language by saying
physical disability illness or other
medical condition
the change is there to provide
clarification for voters who do not have
what they perceive to be a physical
disability
but they can't vote in person because of
health reasons
in 2020 during that cycle
at the height of the pandemic the
legislature worked in a bipartisan
fashion to allow
voters to vote by absentee if they were
concerned about covid by claiming
disability
during that cycle
which was determined to be allowed
we did however receive a significant
amount of feedback from the disability
rights community and constituents with
disabilities who found the conflation of
the potential of getting sick
and disability
as distinct and problematic in the
language so senate bill 427 as amended
acknowledges the seriousness of health
concerns that are separate
from what people perceive as
disabilities and recognizes the very
legitimate feedback that that advocacy
community provided
as i said this this
legislation is very very narrow in scope
and it's really to ensure that when
people are registering when people are
voting by absentee when they're signing
a legal document acknowledging a certain
status whether it's being out of town
whether it's claiming to have a
disability
there are people for whom
the claim of a disability does not seem
given their particular medical status
and this bill attempts to clarify that
to ensure that people can
cast their ballot by absentee with that
i'd be happy to answer any questions of
the committee i also if i may madam
chair i apologize um i did want to also
make note i understand that there were
bills sent over by this committee in the
full house to senate election law that
also deal with some of these statutes
and we are looking at those in senate
election law
working with both you madam chair and
senator gray i think we can resolve any
any differences or overlaps before
things move forward so
with that be happy to
answer any questions the voice of
optimism before across before committees
of conference is a wonderful thing
absolutely madam chair always happy to
work with you and any of the committee
members to resolve as i said any
differences so that we're we're in a
good place and moving forward thank you
and have fewer committees of conference
questions representative bergeron thank
you madam chair
senator thank you um
just a quick question you indicated that
the bill came out of committee on a five
to zero vote am i correct that it also
was approved on
a 24-0 vote on the senate consent
calendar that is correct representative
bergeron it wasn't the consent calendar
it was not removed so it was unanimously
accepted right thank you
seeing none thank you very much for
coming thank you so much also signed up
to speak on sb 427 this morning is linda
bundy
representative quayle you can just pass
welcome back to election ms bundy thank
you
good morning madam chair and members of
the house election law
my name is linda bundy and i'm from
antrim
democracy functions best when every
voter who wants to vote is able to do so
sb 427 increases access to the vote
enabling greater participation
for people who have an illness or
medical condition and wish to vote by
absentee ballot
the only option for them to request the
ballot
is to state that they are disabled
for those who do not consider their
conditions to truly be a disability
to swear or affirm on an affidavit that
they are physically disabled gives them
pause and may be disconcerting enough to
prevent them from voting at all
sb 427 provides a legitimate reason
for voting absentee that these
individuals can swear to with a clear
conscience
this expands the
access to absentee voting reducing a
barrier that exists for some
providing them the opportunity to
exercise this essential civic duty
thank you for your time thank you up
will you take any does anybody have any
questions i know you can do it if
somebody does
all right well nobody does thank you for
coming again
does anybody else here to this morning
want to speak to sb427
thank you
patricia lovejoy from the secretary of
good morning once again patricia lovejoy
secretary of state's office uh the
secretary of state's only comment
would
a recommendation that after physical
disability put including illness or
other medical conditions
so you're not creating a separate
a separate category but you're further
defining physical disability
i have spoken with senator susie prior
to this and i am sure we will have some
more conversations with the secretary of
state between her and secretary of state
regarding this but this is our
recommendation is on the 14 places
in this bill
where you've added illness or other
medical
conditions
to include put the word in
after disability be including illness
or other men or
thank you
any questions representative terozan
thank you madam chair thanks uh
assistant secretary of state for
answering the question
so
in its current form
has the um
have you folks taken a position on this
legislation
our position is that we would prefer to
have it say in
that
illness or other medical condition is
part of the definition of physical
disability physical disability
including illness or other medical
condition that is that is the position
um on the secretary of state's office
right now
thank you madam chair so
in essence with that amendment the
secretary's
secretary of state's office would
support this legislation yes thank you
further questions from committee members
i'm seeing none thank you thank you love
joy
that is the last speaker i have signed
up on 427
seeing no one else i'm going to close
the
the hearing on 427
with permission of the committee i'm
going to reopen
the hearing on
405 i see that senator guida has arrived
perhaps he caught the flight that
senator bradley missed out of florida
i got florida on my mind this morning
because of the
his ability to stay there overnight
again um so we did have a open the
hearing senator i'm reopening the
hearing right now um
representative hayward introduced your
bill for us
so it has already been presented to the
committee so welcome to speak to your
bill madam chair thank you for the
indulgence you offered today
uh we were just down dealing with the
gasoline tax amendment to the bpt
reduction which obviously had a
significant turnout
um
i'm here as uh senator bob dyer from
district two uh and um
a prime sponsor of senate bill 405.
i worked with the attorney general's
office in developing this bill uh as
well
took a look at the the very minimal
possible penalties for things like
vandalism of signs
um
when one considers that that sign is an
expression of the right of free speech
and that a person who vandalizes tears
takes one of those signs is doing much
more than a minor act of vandalism
that's an act of free speech both by the
person who put the sign in the ground
and the person whose property on which
that sign is placed
and for those reasons i i put in
you know the the increased penalties
uh for that i'm happy to walk the
committee through uh the bill
if
i'll relay the story that perhaps is
in one sense gruesome but i i years ago
when i was a member of the house i don't
know who you remembered saggy tahir not
representative here since past
we went to kashmir
in the course of that trip we had a
state dinner with president musharraf in
his cabinet
and i sat next to the minister of
justice and of course in the course of
the dinner we're talking and
and i made mention of the fact that
the amputation of a person's left hand
for stealing a pack of bubble gum seemed
somewhat extreme
and the response was
you don't see many people walking around
with one hand do you
meaning that the penalty was severe
enough
that it tended to disincentivize people
from committing the act
and so that is the purpose behind this
but i also believe
not only is disincentive out of respect
for that first amendment freedom
that raising the penalty is something
that someone is going to really get
hammered with if it if if the attorney
general's office says you know what you
did this now you're now you're now
you're going to pay the price because
it's more than just wrecking a sign
it's in fact infringing on the first
rights the first amendment rights of
both the sign owner and the property
owner i'd be happy to take any questions
questions for senator representative
derozan
thank you madam chair thank you senator
for taking the question
so
with these kinds of instances
fine amount aside
if somebody's
gets caught stealing photo political
signs
it comes down to whether or not the
attorney general's office wants to
pursue
legal action or not correct can you
could it could the person that was um
damaged by this be able to file a suit
without the attorney general's office
willing to do so
not being an attorney i would say i
don't know
i'm not sure whether a court would
would hold you know that this advice i
mean i would file a suit as an amendment
and infringe on my first amendment
rights as the sign holder but you're
going to go that extent for a sign that
cost you five or ten bucks or some of
the largest at four by eight tonight or
a hundred bucks a piece
so um
i don't know that i've answered your
question
i suppose it's up to the
to the property owner or the sign owner
really one following one last follow-up
the only reason they're bringing up
i was thinking a small claims court
where there's minimal cost to do that if
somebody was
damaged in some cases repeatedly
if they would have that option is
another way to do it without tying up
the attorney general's office
right but then if you look at a sign
whose nominal value is five dollars
all right given who's going to go to
small claims court for that right the
point is i think that we need to make
a point that
that sign is an expression of first
amendment freedoms of the sign holder
and the property owner
and for that reason i think that raising
the bar
if you commit that offense you know
we're watching we're the human election
law are saying this is too all right
you're watching a widespread
disrespect
for
constitutional law for law in general
and
the way you can in this instance i think
help to mitigate that is to go ahead and
put a higher penalty on and and i would
say here when you read the language okay
uh
violates orders aids or bets a violation
of the statute relative removing
defacing destroying advertising and
private property doesn't talk about
public property private property and
that's why
shall be subject to a civil penalty of
250 dollars
okay it doesn't say
it does there's no latitude all right
and the attorney general says okay i
bring in the case i have a picture of
film or whatever turns around and goes
you're guilty right there and you are
subject to this fine
um
again again i come back to the
constitutional ramifications of someone
especially removing my expression of
further questions from the committee
representative quailey
thank you madam chairman
uh my question relates to uh section one
uh where it
puts in a new section
so it's uh starting on
line four of page two
which says no person shall use or
threaten force violence or any tactic of
coercion or intimidation to knowingly
discourage interfere with etc or any
election officer
uh and it relates really to the the
second paragraph roman numeral two
whoever violates the provisions of this
section
uh conspires to violate the provisions
shall be guilty of a class b felony
so my interest was focused by the use of
the words discourage intimidate and
intimidation of
not being a legal expert
are there actual
formal definitions of those two words
intimidation and discouraged under the
law and and i ask because
uh intimidation and discouragement seem
to me to have a strong subjective
component at least it's used in
regular english
one person may be intimidated by
something that someone else just doesn't
even
note
so
so my direct question
intimidation and discourage are those
clearly defined under the current law
i don't have the answer to that this was
this language was specifically drafted
by the attorney general and it came out
of some of the results from the last
election in fact the 2020 lectures as
you know was very politically highly
charged well of course of course in
which there were instances um
for example at the
senate bill 43 audit that was done at
the armory right
i went to that numerous times obviously
i was the impetus behind that bill
and there were citizens there whose
action while not physically violent
was definitely attempted to intimidate
and so there is subjectivity here and i
agree with you that could be a concern
i'm not sure how we would fix that okay
uh i i tend to fall on the side of the
citizen
again
if i as a government official
am physically threatened verbally
threatened that's one thing
physically threatened meaning you know
your three-foot circle of personal space
somebody comes within that with me
they're gonna get they're gonna have a
problem
right and so
again we may want to define that better
because i would agree that
i always come down on the side of the
citizen that's just who i am
and i think those words are subjective
enough that they could subject someone
to
you know a class b felonies nothing to
laugh at which is another potential
thing that maybe the committee wants to
look at
uh class b misdemeanor class a
misdemeanor does jail time for a year i
mean that's
that's fairly serious right i mean think
of employment family and those types of
things so
that clause i would agree with you
perhaps the committee might want to look
at that and revise that in the penalty
okay thank you and madam chairman i have
a follow-up question
thank you this is on a
section four
uh
page oh this is page two
uh line 11 except as otherwise provided
in this section whoever violates or
orders aids etc
any provision of this section or rsa 6
subject to civil penalty
for each piece of political advertising
removed
as a little puzzled a little puzzled by
this because
section 664 14 refers to
as i understood it basically the fact
you have to identify who put the
advertising out
and there's no reference in
664 14 that i could find in my looking
at it
regarding removal of signs so i'm a
little
and the version of the of the that rsa
i'm using i downloaded off the state
website so
okay
i can't answer that
i don't have an answer for you okay
that's fine
further questions from committee members
madam chair
representative bergeron
thank you madam chair thank you senator
um
what about an instance and i know this
happens because it's happened to me
before
when another candidate puts his sign on
another person's private property
without asking permission to do so does
the
property owner have the right to remove
that sign absolutely okay
your
your bill wouldn't uh impact you
wouldn't address that no okay thank you
i'm seeing none
thank you for coming over this morning
senator thank you chair griffin and
members of the committee for your
indulgence
and i'll leave a pink card here
all right thank you i'm going to close
the the hearing on
405 close it again
and i believe that concludes our
business here this morning
you should have all received an addendum
calendar we have a meeting at 10 o'clock
public hearings on our three
remaining bills we will be following
that
going trying to
do executive session on a few bills
unless we have amendments or specific
requests to continue the hearing the
bills at this time i am planning on exec
would be 242
and
that is
subject to
further information being received by
the chair but there will be no interest
there will be no exec on any bill other
than those four
and we have scheduled an executive
session for next week on wednesday
which will be for all of the remaining
bills we have a total of 10 bills in
this committee from the senate
all bills must be acted on and reported
out by next week so with that i want to
thank everybody this morning and our
election law committee public hearing is
over
have a great
you